foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week
where you decide who is the bonehead of
the week and we break it down every
single Friday in the second hour the
Tony Michaels podcast
on YouTube Twitter twitch live every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page
bonehead of the week it's just this this
has got to be one of my favorite
segments it's fun it's been a long I
mean we've been doing it for a long time
you actually you texted me last night
you said hey the the voting organic
growth that the Voting is going up you
people love it every week this week was
like I don't know 1300 votes and that's
just on Twitter last week was like
around 800 votes so it's like that's
right that's just we were we were late
yesterday putting yeah and people were
flocking to it wait what about pull out
huh did you say pull out pull no no no
no no I'm not talking about cat noven
and yeah I got it got it
yeah there's probably some other people
on bonehead of the week that could have
you know should have pulled out oh maybe
maybe a dishonorable mention or
something yeah maybe his last name
wouldn't be musk would it
um it smells a little musky does it
smell musky in here it might I don't
know I don't know so we did we did have
three
um really bone-headed [ __ ] the
craziest part about when we put these
when we when we put this bowl out I
noticed I was like oh God these are all
[ __ ] elected members of of our
government what in the actual [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] kidding me now obviously
when we've gone through some of this
before but these [ __ ] could be
on this list again we have to say this
every goddamn week these people could be
on the list every week and we had a ton
of comments where's the all of the above
where's the all of the the above right
because here's the thing all three of
these [ __ ] came out of the same
[ __ ]
they all came out of the same you mean
like the same pile of [ __ ] or yeah yeah
they all kind of like brewed out you
know uh but no it's it you know it had
to do with comments that were made
during a hearing that they sat on for
different things two of them I believe
on the same kind of on the same
committee panel and but they're all
related to the same sort of thing yeah
yeah well you know we we missed the
Holly video the other day because we
went through the Uvaldi
um the Rob Elementary footage from the
hallways of the of the Uvaldi
um Elementary School there
so we missed the Holly video so we
played it yesterday where he's just
getting absolutely [ __ ] torched and I
felt like that was the biggest
bone-headed movement our move that was
made so I actually I did I did vote I
did vote for Josh Hawley um okay I went
with the Jim Jordan route you know a lot
of people went with Jim Jordan but you
know really honestly for Jim Jordan to
look the other way of a sexual assault
yeah is bone-headed but it's not
surprising right I was really surprised
that Josh Hawley walked into you know he
really he really he he's a bonehead
because he thought that this woman was
stupid you know he automatically thinks
that women are dumb right exactly and
that was and that was I think his dumb
bone-headed mood it's not surprising
that Jim he walked into it and then he
just kind of stomped around in it and
was like what what is this is this [ __ ]
I'm in right right well he is he is a
pilot [ __ ] for sure and and we played
that video yesterday of of Josh Ollie
being a bonehead now why is what's the
reason why Matt gatz is on this list is
there a specific reason yeah yeah yeah
it's just Matt Getz well he tried to oh
my God in some ass backwards way tried
to seem like the good guy
and and Matt gatz tried to seem like the
good yeah he tried to because what he
says there's a clip
um I can send you the the link but
basically in this hearing he tries to he
tries to say how he was the good guy
that voted for a bill in Florida that
was around the lgbtq community and
protecting them and then he tried to say
in the same kind of breath throw that
Community under the bus and say that
abortions
would uh well I mean
basically trying to talk about uh
lesbian and bisexual relationships one
not really understanding what they were
and two tried to use again yeah his
place attempting to argue that lesbian
rape vict survivors should uh keep
unwanted pregnancies so safe sex couples
can adopt them because he tried to say
same-sex couples adopt at a higher rate
than heterosexual couples and he's
saying that if they what don't have
babies then it's less opportunity for
same-sex couples to adopt
it's it's [ __ ] bananas to for four
minutes you watch him really try to make
this case and seem like he's a total
protector of the lgbtq community
and it doesn't go the way that he wants
because he keeps digging and it it just
like Holly he gets [ __ ] stepping in
the [ __ ] and smearing it it's all
[ __ ] through the tread marks of the
shoes and he's not getting it out have
you ever watched a kid when he steps in
a big pile of dog [ __ ] on the curb
trying to scrape trying to scrape the
dog [ __ ] yeah off the bottom of his shoe
and it just gets worse like he gets it
up on his [ __ ] leg and he's and then
he's got so much [ __ ] how big is this
[ __ ] and then he's got a stick he's
sitting on the curb trying to pick this
[ __ ] out of his shoes
is this something that happened to you
recently no no I've watched I've watched
the kid do this your kid not my kid no
my kid's not this [ __ ] done I'm
talking about Matt Getz as he was a kid
and I when I was a kid you know there
were some dumb [ __ ] around you know
there gets tights you know my cats types
the privileged kids who [ __ ] up and then
their dad saves them when they get a DUI
yeah you know you gotta stick and you're
trying to pick the dog [ __ ] out of here
and then you might flick up like a dog
[ __ ] booger up on your face or something
oh God yeah I know that that's meant
gets probably in this clip that's all I
wanted to start my Friday uh well you
can never be disappointed with me here
it's fine on the bonehead of the week so
let's let's play the clip of Matt Getz
uh trying to get the dog [ __ ] out of his
shoes this war glow what's the most
likely circumstance when a same-sex
couple would benefit from abortion
access
unfortunately we have women who
experience sexual assault in fact uh
lesbian and bisexual women are more
likely to experience sexual assault than
heterosexual women that their
pregnancies are often involuntary and so
these are individuals who would need
access to abortion care and we'll shelve
the bisexual wound for a moment since my
questions about the same-sex couples and
what's more likely
he's like I'm gonna talk about I'm gonna
talk about bisexual women here in a
minute if you watch his body language
right now he seems kind of nervous like
he's like playing with his hands and
he's like
he's kind of not as smooth in his in his
speaking here probably because he
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about but also because he's trying to
you'll see in a second really tries to
make himself out to be the good guy here
and he's the saving paid like the the
[ __ ] Patriot saint of of the LG
community and saying how he's helping
he's trying to help same-sex couples by
not allowing abortions so in the dog
[ __ ] stepping in scenario this is the
moment when the kid
realizes he stepped in the big pile of
dogs yeah yeah that's the moment
damn it damn it
I mean you you stepped in a big pile of
dog [ __ ] before right yeah you know the
feeling you know you know the you know
the feeling that comes over you when you
step in that baby that's where that's
where Mac Edge is here you don't even
have to see it if you stepped in before
you know
and that's exactly where Matt Getz is
right now this feeling he's like because
that's why he had to shelf the bicycle
he hasn't quite looked down yet he's
stepped in and he's like please don't
let that be [ __ ] please don't let that
be [ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ] this is where it
goes in there let's let's watch a
lesbian woman having an unwanted
pregnancy as the consequence of a sexual
assault or a gay couple adopting in
America
these are both laudable goals no I
didn't ask I know they are which is more
likely
I think that's uh impossible to know
whether or not we have tens of thousands
of same-sex couples that are look at the
guy behind him the guy behind him is
like you are a dumb [ __ ] yeah
and that's that's someone who's on his
side there yeah right he's like God I
told you not to ask this question Jesus
[ __ ] are you talking about here this is
ridiculous Jesus or raising families and
uh raising children yeah as a
consequence of adoption tens of
thousands we know that uh as a
consequence of census data so is there
any data you're able to reference that
it would be more likely for a lesbian
woman to have an unwanted pregnancy as a
consequence of rape than the formation
of a family through a same-sex couple
adopting it may not be more likely but
it's an important interest is it less
likely I'm not asking about the
importance of the interests are very
limited on time the question is thank
God you're limited on time thank [ __ ]
God you are limited on time because your
stupidity is just astounding absolutely
[ __ ] astounding not only only not
only should Matt Getz not be talking
about anything to do with the woman's
body because he clearly does not
understand he should definitely
definitely not be talking about family
issues or not be surmising on [ __ ]
people raping people this is a
[ __ ] that is is being
investigated for sexual assault of a
minor
okay sex trafficking a minor what in the
actual [ __ ] is happening here Jesus
[ __ ] Christ I mean this dog [ __ ] just
gets smellier and stinkier and it's now
coming up on the sides of the shoes like
it's about to get into the fabric and
once it goes in the fabric you ain't
getting that [ __ ] out right nope that
shit's not coming out is certain you
would concede that it's certainly more
that it's more likely in America that
you have same-sex couples adopting than
you do lesbians having unwanted
pregnancies as a consequence of sexual
assault right well there may be also be
a misunderstanding about how uh same-sex
couples form families I also think it's
important to note that many bisexual
women are in fact in relationships with
other women
but but if a woman is with men and women
they're bisexual right that is not true
sir an individual who
he's like wait a second wait a second I
met me one of them one of them what she
calls them what you calls him there lady
one of them by I met one in bisexuals
before like what the [ __ ] is this guy
talking about it's well he's like okay
are you getting confused with a like
non-like monogamous relationship like at
the same time would imply that one
either you're you know involved in a
threesome right or two you're you're in
a a non-monogamous relationship right
you're dating multiple partners that
could be male and female right but he's
trying to be like
you're with both male and female that's
what no right that's not necessarily
true just because you have an attraction
to both sexes doesn't mean you're you're
only bisexual when you're dating both of
them and that's it and it's right he's
such a [ __ ] bonus see that's that's
the problem is these [ __ ] idiots are
so goddamn stupid they have smoked and
done and drank all their [ __ ] brain
cells away that they can't imagine they
can't imagine any kind of sexuality
other than their [ __ ] own and I
understand that maybe Matt gatz does
understand a bisexual sexuality but he
clearly he clearly does not have the
brain power to really compute it outside
his own [ __ ] head like he just does
not have the brain power to understand
that other people are gonna have
different [ __ ] belief systems they're
gonna have different World Views they're
gonna have different sexualities man it
happens man it happens stay the [ __ ] out
of their [ __ ] business would you please
also just because a woman doesn't want
to date you or be around you doesn't
make her a lesbian just makes that she
has standards and doesn't want to be
involved with anyone like she thinks
every woman has a lesson do you think
that's why I think
he's like they don't like to talk to me
they're all lesbians exactly he'd be
like oh that [ __ ] she's a lesbian
guarantee any woman
physically assault and she wasn't having
it and stood up for herself maybe
[ __ ] smacked him or said nope not
into it he was like go back to his
friends and goes she's a [ __ ] lesbian
dudes she wasn't having it it's like why
wouldn't any why wouldn't any women want
to have this gay and it's like the fact
that you had to ask that question right
here we go it was retracted to people of
both sexes both men and women
is bisexual they can be in long-term
monogamous relationships yeah I don't
ask this to be dismissive but so you're
saying lesbian women are also capable of
being into men that is not what I said I
said bisexual yeah but my question is
about lesbians same-sex comments right
because I I care about this issue deeply
with the support of the Human Rights
Campaign I sponsored the legislation to
get rid of the statutory prohibition on
gay adoption in Florida I felt that was
very bigoted and I believe families are
defined by love more than blood and I
was wondering
btq community and if the advocacy
organizations for same-sex couples
somehow reorients to be maybe maybe he's
trying to get answers here he's not
actually asking for America maybe he's
asking for himself I I have an adopted
son who's not blood but it's love you
know and it's like are you are you
trying to tell us something about Nestor
right now he's trying to really figure
out bisexuality he's like I got rid of
this law but Nest is not my blood but I
see him in more than blood what is by
defined bisexual again for me again
please tell me exactly what it would
would be let's just give the scenario if
I was a bisexual meanwhile the guy
behind him is like oh [ __ ] look at
this guy he's like Jesus Christ he's
like is his time up is his time he's
like I hate that I have to be here right
now Jesus Christ pro-abortion Enterprise
that could actually result in fewer
same-sex couples having access to the
family formation that gives them okay I
can't I can't I can't anymore because
the prohibition of abortion actually
makes it to where some same-sex couples
won't be able to do procedures to give
them their own blood family you [ __ ]
boneheads but also the fact that he's
trying to say that if we if we allow a
DOT if we allow abortions it'll bring
down the number of adoptions within
same-sex couples okay first off there
are plenty of kids who are in the
unfortunate situation that are in an
orphanage or their you know their Wards
the state or or whatever it might be
that they have no you know they don't
have longer have a family right they
have been put up for adoption they live
a home like these are kids
there are a ton of children again
unfortunate situation that there are a
ton of children who do not have homes
you know what I think I can almost we
can almost take a screenshot of this and
and do the Tweet we'll adopt your
children with these two definitely
definitely but I look at I look at Matt
Gates and he's trying to make this weird
[ __ ] assumption that adoption that
there's a direct relationship with uh
you know or an indirect relationship to
say like increase in adoption decrease
in or increase in abortion decrease in
adoption among same-sex couples like
where the [ __ ] do you get that logic
like the pretzel Twisted gears turning
and Matt Gates's head he's like I'm
making a good point here and everyone
else that's watching this even the guy
behind him is like
Matt I told you this was not well it's
not a good idea he's like I he's like I
gave you the numbers and you kept
telling your you know confirmation bias
he's like yeah but then there's less
babies and less babies mean less adopted
children and it's like Matt that's not
at all what's going on here he's such a
[ __ ] bonehead man gets is such a
[ __ ] bonehead and I'm glad he made it
on bone of the week and I'm actually sad
that I gave my vote to Josh Hawley now
now that I I watched this clip I wish I
could go back and change my vote uh stop
the steal stop the steal
um please someone commit voter fraud and
change my vote dude dumbest dumbest
[ __ ] argument I've ever heard it is
kind of pathetic um we do I I want to
make time for the alpha cook but we do
have a new arrival here on bone of the
week and this honorable mention because
we've had a musk here before several
times but this is a new one yeah this is
a new musk this is how do you say his
name is it Carol Arrow Arrow Arrow musk
who is this musk Gabe who is this this
is the father
of Elon Musk oh this is the one who gave
Elon Musk the money you know because
remember Elon Musk is not self-made he
got money from his family so so what
does his father do is he in charge of
some kind of like minds or something
where yeah yeah
you know South Africa I think he's an
engineer uh if I remember the title
crackle but yeah he made his money in
the minds of South Africa where the
origin of the money that Elon Musk got
to kind of start his his
entrepreneurship Venture
um
yeah surely this guy is not is not in
the news here and on bonehead because
he's a scuzz bag I'm sure that's not
what no not at all not at all it can't
be I mean this is what happened
let's start in the morning Woody Allen
was like hey guys I'm into dating my
daughter and then Errol musk said uh
hold my beer
and then entered the chat and because
this [ __ ] is crazy and the the reasoning
for why he did what he did
is and you see it on the screen here I'm
sure I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure
his reasoning makes all the sense when
you read the headline here Elon Musk
father
Errol musk announces he has welcomed a
second child not a not a child a second
child with his stepdaughter yeah who has
raised who he has raised since she was
four years old this is really [ __ ]
gross the only thing we are on earth is
for for is to reproduce
oh my [ __ ] god so wait a second so is
he still married to her mother is it
is it is that what it is I believe so so
I don't know any I don't know any
different I mean who knows these guys
should come ask questions about how I
know it's like right so how does this
work how does this work if I wanna Matt
Getz could be like wait a second so I
have a doctor son yeah if I got a a
stepdaughter an adopted son do I get to
you know what's the what's how does that
work and you probably start asking that
[ __ ] in committee you know just to
figure this out I mean you might as well
this is the second child the second
now Elon Musk has said the same stupid
thing of course we've seen the Elon [ __ ]
where he's got kids he he knew about and
or he had twins last week or I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on with this
I mean the guy's got elon's got 10 kids
right that we know of I wonder where he
gets it from I wonder where he gets it
from yeah yeah yeah yeah it's one of
those things where it's uh
I mean it's [ __ ] gross but like
spread it you gotta spread the seed you
know you gotta you got a fertilizer and
grow grow your garden in them in the
Bounty that is earth right
there's um
uh I'm blanking on it right at home one
second well the rotten apple does not
fall far from the tree here oh not at
all that's for sure for certain the
rotten apple does not fall far
from the nasty old tree because we I
mean elon's been in the news again he's
he's had a riff with Trump
um and recently over him walking away
and pulling out of Twitter the one time
he did pull out well he's pulled out a
lot he just
doesn't like to um pull out on other
things he likes to trade horses away for
it
um
it's enhanced for horses whichever way
you want to go first musk and apparently
Arrow musk now too Jesus [ __ ] Christ
um
oh I gotta really I'm gonna take a drink
of water I got a nasty taste of my mouth
oh it's fine I mean you know I I had
some mouthwash earlier the uh
you are [ __ ] gross be well also
there's if anyone has watched the
Netflix documentary Our Father which I
definitely recommend there's a cult yes
yes there's a cult that he's in which is
the quiverful right and it's that same
this is these wait wait Arrow musk is in
that cult no no I don't know if he's no
I don't know I don't know what I'm
saying is in that documentary which I
definitely recommend to anyone this is
not sponsored uh
in that documentary they talk about a
cult that um the doctor's involved with
is called quiverful right and it's a
Christian cult that is the ideology is
to be fruitful and multiply and you know
blah blah as many kids as possible
that's the same type of thinking the
same type of ideology or or thinking
that um
that Elon and arrow must have right they
want as many kids they want to spread
the Bounty of Earth you know they want
to spread their seed they want to
multiply like that's that [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] you know and I don't know if it's
because they actually believe in it who
knows but
they definitely have the same line of
thinking to have as many kids as
possible you know well their Elon again
has been in the news he's gonna get sued
by Twitter oh yeah and you know when we
we went through that but I want to go to
before we get to the winner
um because I definitely want to spend
some time on on the winner because it is
very gross what the winner did this week
but really honestly the entire
right-wing apparatus followed him in in
this Pursuit yeah they followed him into
the dark trying to prove something that
was very easily uh proven as fact they
called it a lie and they've shamed a
little girl
um so we're gonna get to that but I want
to go to this Alpha cook looks like
we're getting back to Mr Stein here I
had to I had to so why why did you of
course we watched the video earlier
right on the show of him and merge
Mercury foot green emerge talking about
you know downplaying the fact that he
was sexually harassing uh AOC on the
capital steps and it wasn't funny it was
sexual harassment is what it was
um you know jokes are funny and sexual
harassment is not funny right so so it
wasn't funny Alex but why why do you
have him here on the uh dishonorable
yeah yeah yeah okay so the the main
reason is uh for his you know misogyny
right his attack on AOC okay the defense
that he has to say it's just a joke
right right I really like her all this
stuff but here's the thing Alex Stein is
you know has attacked other people
whether it be Ted Cruz or it be uh
uh
eye patch McCain I'm Patrick McCain
right Dan Crenshaw which I've attacked
him I I have said I have said Dan
Crenshaw needs to get a [ __ ] glass
eye and wear it yeah just like last
action heroes with the glass eye in boom
done you could do cool stuff right so
Alex Stein I just you know the the
commitment to double down right so he
goes on it wasn't until I watched a clip
of Margie Taylor green when I was like
nah [ __ ] this guy he's going on Alpha
cook now the history of of uh of Alex
Stein is that there's anyone who doesn't
know this nobody he's got a show uh that
is about
um it's called conspiracy Castle right
and I'm gonna play a clip from a
what he considers to be stand up and
there's actually a well so this is where
the comedian part comes in where he's
right right so he you may have seen him
on Tucker Carlson or he does a bit or
multiple bits when he goes to like Town
Hall committee you know kind of meetings
right there are people that troll
committee means really well there are
the two guys from San Diego area
right this is this the guy that was down
in Texas that went and he there's a
video of him he made the rap yeah
there's the rap one he did the one where
he showed up with a mask he did a really
over 19. yeah yeah so there are people
that show up to these meetings that are
either completely serious right which
you're like [ __ ] this guy is crazy or
they're people that go into medians and
they try to they try to troll and they
try to make a joke of it right the
people that I've seen do it really well
there are two two friends that think
it's San Diego they try to get the Paul
Walker statue made like viral videos
where they go in and there's like a
couple Surfer Bros and we're just like
talk into the committee here and we want
to get Paul Walker a statue you know
stuff like that which is like you know
it's trivial but it's funny right
not not attacking a group it's just like
good fun
now you've got people like Alex Stein
who show up and do crazy [ __ ] they're
mocking science making fun of people who
had covid uh they're making fun of women
they're misogynists doing attacks here
and there but it's on to the name of
right funny it's funny you just don't
get it you don't get the sarcasm it's
like well what what purpose
you just don't get it
so anyway that's the thing that Alex
Stein does now what people might not
know
is he's actually a reality TV star oh
whoa so you surprised me when saying
that this [ __ ] box right so he was on a
reality TV show called ABC's The Glass
House oh uh he only lasted two episodes
then he was on CNC voted off
uh I believe so it just I can't imagine
you can't I can't imagine yeah yeah
really wide you know what what word and
so then he was on cmt's uh Sweet Home
Alabama and worst Cooks in America and
the food networks the Food Network in
2013 which I wasn't able to find it so
is he like a career reality TV star or
something I think so that's where he's
making that's around here you know yeah
I know so most people know him for his
you know uh his dumb takes on in these
in these meetings and stuff or on Tucker
Carlson right as the white Power Hour as
he said but he's also been on another
show which is a Bravo series called
online dating rituals of the American
male
oh right and it was a doctor series
sounds like ball tanning uh yep 100
games if you look at the guys that were
on the show it's a bunch of basically uh
preppy white dudes kind of you know they
could all be the alpha cook yeah yeah
so that one is a docu-series that we're
supposed to unmask the world of the
booming this is in 2000 uh 14 or
something I think or it's on 15. uh yeah
the booming online dating culture from
the male perspective because who who
doesn't want to learn more about what
it's like for a white male or a bunch of
waiting baby white dudes yeah he's like
I tried to talk to this girl at the bar
and then she told me to [ __ ] off and
then I was like huh she's a lesbian so
now I've heard that before yeah crazy
yeah I know they're all the same they're
like you didn't like me she's a lesbian
so all these guys these white guys who
are triggered or you know whatever can't
get their date because you know being
themselves is not actually attractive uh
it follows these men as they hunt
for their ideal partner or hook up
whatever might be
so you get an inside perspective of the
male psyche from the beginning stages of
trolling and communicating online to
Landing a date with a potential match
this guy is a piece of [ __ ] all right I
watch clips of the show uh where he is
the villain like and they knew when they
casted this show they knew exactly who
they were getting okay so they they
found this guy's an [ __ ] right he's
gonna be the villain of the show you
know and he plays that role really well
right he I mean he's not a great villain
but he's just an [ __ ] on the show
where he's like talking about girls
waiting like that's the role that he's
playing now it's a question of like are
are we acting in this role like are we
are we kind of ratcheting this roll up
or are you playing true to the Persona
that you are and I believe based on
clips that I've seen and different
things like Alex Stein 99
isn't a character Alex die 99 is
actually Alex Stein oh so there's a
Bonafide piece of [ __ ] oh dude Bonafide
[ __ ] phone F5 piece of [ __ ] so I hope
that you know we tag Alex Stein he can
come here and watch the show you know
yeah people can I I hope Allison knows
yeah I hope so too so there's a clip
[ __ ] him where he goes and does what he
calls stand up now whether he means it
in an ironic fashion he's like oh it's
not really stand up it's just me I mean
he's standing up he's standing he's
standing up it's in a South Dallas Club
he's a white guy in preppy clothing like
that's his his shtick right that's Alex
Stein 99. but in this clip he talks of a
lot of various [ __ ] right he talks about
uh Harris as uh as potential president
but this
although we have to watch this douchebag
this clip I believe is uh
uh one no it's 34 seconds I only clipped
out one section which is he talks about
the private prison industry and you
might have to upload it did you upload
it I put it on the show I mean I can
upload it sure yeah you might you might
want to upload it so it's decent because
when we play it across the internet it
has right right right right so so
basically
um
in this in this stand-up routine
whatever you want to call it but he
calls it stand up he goes in there and
he's talking about the private prison
industry and he talks about music and
how it's like this this uh
uh this kind of Beast that eats itself
the the prison industry uh the music
industry tells the you know to commit
these crimes and go into prison and the
prison industry says to be successful
you got to make music and it's a cycle
right but in there
he spreads uh misinformation or
disinformation because I know he is 100
because he brings up a name and he says
this person from the black community oh
owns a stake in private prison industry
uh-oh turns out that's not true
so you're just making [ __ ] up he's just
making because it's funny Gabe it's
funny right should I go and play the
yeah okay let's play it then stop there
listen this is why I want to help all my
black brothers and sisters and then in
the 80s they got all the top record
Executives and this is they said they
said oh we got to have black music that
influences violence and drug use why
because we invested in all the private
prisons so what we're gonna do is all
the record labels own all the private
prisons so you're going to influence
black people to go to jail to fill up
their private prisons and you're like
Alex what the hell that can't be true
looking at one of the biggest guys that
owns private prisons Michael Jordan has
one of the biggest investors in private
business so that
okay so let me just tell you right here
none of that was jokes none of it yeah
none of that none of that none of that
clip jokes jokes all of it all of it was
in a room uh looking at at black people
being racist in front of black guys and
it looked like they had their cameras at
like we gotta film this fact because
they almost feel like this white dude's
got some balls he's saying some the
whole set that I have here is seven
minutes I was like [ __ ] it this is the
only part that I want to show but he
talks about a ton of random [ __ ] in here
and and talking you know about
everything from prisons to music what's
the music in the background no I when
they edit did he edit it like that I
think I think so yeah yeah the title is
Alex Alex Alex Stein keeps it real in
the hood Alex Alex listen if you aren't
listening out there number one I I'm not
the best video editor between the two
guys on the screen but I do know this
you should really keep your background
music down so you can hear like the
action maybe he realized the jokes the
jokes weren't good all right so and he
was like I got music yeah I got to cover
this up you know so here's the thing he
claims he goes oh yeah because you know
he's trying to make a point here right
he's trying to say how how products
right you know uh people within the
black community are are products of the
prison industry and those who are
successful whether it be through sports
or or music or whatever try to get other
people in the black community back
through the prison system right because
he says it's like a Revenge kind of
thing like well I think it's like he's
trying to make some argument on how like
I don't know ownership or something you
know some dumb [ __ ] B's like not he's
like look white people aren't the bad
ones it's also black people because
black people own the prison industry
it's [ __ ] because here's the thing
he's trying to infer and tell you to
like oh yeah Michael Jordan how many
Michael Jordan's do you know right you
know two right but but you probably only
know one that he's referring to which is
Michael basketball Jordan
here's the thing it's not that Michael
Jordan there is a Michael Jordan that
does own a stake in the private prison
industry but it is not Michael Jordan
the NBA All-Star from the Bulls okay
that is not the person but of course he
goes there to make a point and says oh
[ __ ] there's a guy named Michael Jordan
this is totally gonna back up my thing
right and so he does that to be like oh
yeah Michael Jordan from the Bulls
that's who that's what I'm talking about
instead of some random Michael Jordan
some Rando some random but this is the
type of [ __ ] that Alex Stein does right
he's gonna he'll he he goes just like
his daddy his [ __ ] daddy and the
white Power Hour Tucker Carlson his
point is that he wants to make it he
wants to make a claim he will uh he will
not have evidence to back it up and if
he does have something that somewhat
sounds like it he will finesse it to
make his point right it's what Ben
Shapiro does
um it's what Charlie Kirk does it's what
uh Jordan uh Peterson does like all of
these guys are the same type of people
they're ball Tanners Alpha cucks want to
get with women but get pissed off when
they don't like you and so then they
take it back out on a woman and say it's
a joke it's a joke
it's really it's really hell yeah let me
tell you I'm a comedian and a stand-up
that's you know and again he's like well
you don't get I guarantee if he sees
this he'll be like well you don't get
the humor it's supposed to be like
ironic like it's anti-comedy right and
it's like but it's not if you're just
making [ __ ] up it's almost like someone
else we have ran into the last couple
weeks who doesn't also understand
satire and comedy either but you know I
guess we only have one alpha cut per
week so we give it to Alex Stein let's
move on to the winner of the bonehead of
the week Jim Jordan this was like it was
a blowout with this [ __ ] idiot yeah
um the real the reason why is because
Jim Jordan is almost as much as Trump as
the king of Maga Jim Jordan might be the
king of boneheads I don't know what do
you think is that I mean look the guy's
been in how many years how many years
has he been in let's see Jim Jordan
he's been in uh a week was way too long
yeah yeah let's see Jim Jordan years in
Congress
16 17. uh he has been in office since
2007 so 15 almost 16 years right and
still and still doesn't own a [ __ ]
jacket doesn't own a jacket
has not passed a bill
the only thing he has to his name is
that he helped cover up the sexual
assault
um claims and that were a part of the
wrestling team when when he was at um
uh Ohio State yeah Ohio State and
now
to his name he's adding the fact that
he's going to throw a 10 year old girl
under the bus and say that it's all made
up because here's the store a big scam a
10 year old girl was raped in Ohio she
got pregnant
um because Republicans and fascists
don't want little little babies to have
babies in this country right
um because they're gonna Force big
government pregnancy on a 10 year old
girl they don't want her to have an
abortion in Ohio so she had to go to
Indiana now there's some disgusting [ __ ]
that happened with the attorney general
and still continue napping with the
attorney general over in Indiana because
he's a slime ball too just like Jim
Jordan here but Jim Jordan tweeted that
it was fake and the reason why they
tweet is because Joe Biden talked about
the story in front of a microphone so
they just assumed anything Joe Biden
says a [ __ ] lie and it wasn't just
him it was all of them every [ __ ]
last one of them said it was all a lie
because they're like oh where's the guy
who raped her did you arrest him did you
arrest it and they arrested him and then
and then he deleted the [ __ ] tooth
that said it and here is the clip of Jim
Jordan being asked about why he [ __ ]
deleted that tweet the American people
want to know you piece of [ __ ] you're an
elected official why are you [ __ ]
denigrating a little child who who
you're you're you're advocating for big
government to force her to have a baby
you piece of [ __ ] let's see what he says
it's probably bone-headed I'm sure you
voted for him why'd you delete the
Twitter well because we learned that
this illegal alien that this thing is
wrong you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] so here he is he
he obviously has the chance here to own
up to why he deleted that but he won't
no he won't he won't I mean what would
be the excuse if it was not you know you
know legal alien right oh they are super
excited super excited about the person's
name I mean it's exactly like what
happened with Uvaldi they were like they
immediately went to oh he's hispanic oh
oh and you know what he's definitely
from he's definitely a legal alien and
you're like nah he's from [ __ ] South
Dakota okay right he's not he's the
opposite side of the [ __ ] border he's
got closer to Canada than Mexico and
also the Assumption like he's Mexican he
came over the border and he went right
in Uvalde and he was like I hate
Americans
that's the same type of [ __ ] right you
had people and then even after the fact
of that that situation where they all
jumped on the bad wagon to say he was
illegal
nobody nobody said oh [ __ ] got it wrong
or I'm gonna delete this tweet right
right but if your code the code for vets
or whatever the [ __ ] one was uh the
the veteran uh Twitter account doubled
down
and didn't even delete the Tweet right
and they were like oh you know it's
mental health right so they'll always
jump from the next thing and this is
where they're like here here it is so
good he's illegal well and the reason
why they're terrified of this story
because this trash is the reason why
they want Roe v Wade and we watch a
[ __ ] clip also where someone tried to
claim that a 10 year old girl having an
abortion is not an abortion because
she's a 10 year old girl which makes no
sense whatsoever they're doing
everything they can about this story
yeah to [ __ ] not have the American
people vote against them in the midterm
which I believe is coming but let's
listen to what else is [ __ ] bone and
has to say
um
girl in the family for suggesting
they're alive I never doubted the child
yeah [ __ ] bull get the [ __ ] out of
here okay I've had enough of this piece
of [ __ ] I never doubted the child you
literally said it was fake [ __ ] you said
it was fake you said it wasn't real and
you're like oh yeah here comes another
one of these fake stories coming out of
Joe Biden and the left wing media and
it's like
well I I wish I had time I'd show a clip
of uh Eric swalwell Eric swallow did
such a good job of just
wanting Jim Jordan up and throwing him
in the [ __ ] trash about this story oh
yeah I wish I had actually you know what
let's yes let's let's do it yesterday
Miss warbelow speaking of disinformation
Jim Jordan called a ten-year-old rape
victim a liar
a ten-year-old rape victim was called a
liar by the ranking member of this
committee and I know that he did that
because he hates the president it's
clear every day from his statements and
the statements from Mega Republicans
that they don't like Joe Biden so
they're going to call him a liar that's
fine but what is worse is the reason
that he did it is because he doesn't
like
what that rape victim represents which
is that this law
from the Supreme Court Dobbs and the
laws that will follow in States like
Ohio and Texas and Georgia and other
states
will bring us government mandated
pregnancies for 10 year olds
fourth graders little girls babies and
to deflect from that yeah they choose to
bully and beat up
transgender individuals who represent
fewer than one percent of Americans and
they try and deflect that because they
don't want anyone in America to realize
that they don't just want to wage a war
on women
they're now expanding it to a war on
little girls so miss warbelow let's go
back to where we started here
boom that is how you slam dunk that
[ __ ] in the chat trash thank you
Eric swalwell uh let's give Jim Jordan
His due for bonehead of the [ __ ] week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no contest Jim Jordan is the bonehead of
the week not even not even a [ __ ]
prayer thought or prayer yeah that the
other boneheads had with Jim Jordan
calling a 10 year old girl a liar when
the big when she wanted to force a big
government pregnancy on her and force
her to carry a baby to term [ __ ] that
guy [ __ ] all these boneheads really oh
yeah especially [ __ ] [ __ ] Jim Jordan
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ] em make sure to
follow us at Tony Michaels pod go vote
every single week for bone in the week
we will break it down in the second hour
on the YouTube channel don't forget to
subscribe there we broadcast live every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific from
YouTube Twitter and twitch and simulcast
from the Midas touch Facebook page also
what we do with bone end of the week
Gabe is we actually clip it out and play
it on Sunday exactly fine just bonehead
of the week on Sundays and
yeah when it comes out on Sunday make
sure to tag Alex Stein 99 that's it
that's it
shred it around all right spread it like
herpes which I'm sure he has all right
I'm sure I'm sure Alex it happens it
happens it happens Alex happens to the
best of us it happens well that has been
bonehead of the week thanks for joining
us stick around we have some
announcements right after this foreign
[Applause]
[Music]